on this sunday night
canada's metal count grows two more
bronze medals in one of the most
exciting days of the games
and i think we're just getting started
as canada's penny olexiac makes history
covet 19 takes aim at the unprotected as
a fourth wave
looms the next wave i think will be
largely in children
more political turmoil in myanmar and
allegations the military is weaponizing
covet 19.
and canada marks its first emancipation
day
and the push to engage more black
communities in politics
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
eric sorenson
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
canadians had plenty to cheer for at the
olympics today
two more bronze medals one that made
history
and the other in the most watched 10
seconds in sports
canadian sprinter andre de grasse ran
his fastest time ever in the 100 meters
he captured bronze and became the first
canadian male
to reach the podium in tokyo until today
the women
have been bringing home the hardware and
four of them captured another bronze in
the pool today
in the 4 by 100 medley relay and it was
all the more monumental for one of those
athletes
penny oleksiak who became canada's most
decorated olympian
ever crystal gomensing has tonight's top
story
olympic glory and canadian history
pennyolexiax swam her way into the
record books with her teammates
kylie moss maggie mcneal and sydney
pickram
i think we honestly have the best team
in the world and i think we're just
getting started and
i'm excited to see how many medals the
swim team is going to bring canada in
the next
couple olympics alexia at just 21 has
seven olympic medals more than any other
canadian
one gold two silver and now four bronze
her teammate and gold medalist mcneal
feels it's a record
that will stand i don't think it will be
reached for a very long time
if ever but it's definitely inspiring
and
do it with her is even more incredible
incredible is a great way to describe
the race the team set a canadian record
swimming the medley relay in three
minutes 52.60 seconds
picker who swam the breaststroke reacted
honestly and off the cuff
saying in a live post-win interview that
during her leg
she was asking herself at the end they
were just people
i'm just a 24 year old and yeah i will
end up saying that sometimes and
um i just didn't really think anything
of it but my brother loved the comment
the other s word of the day sprinting
if you blinked you may have missed andre
degrasse
he set a personal record in tokyo
running the 100 meters
in 9.89 seconds winning back-to-back
olympic bronze medals for the 100 meter
sprint
degrasse is also the first man to win a
medal at these games for
canada he could also pick up another one
the 200 meter sprint is on tuesday back
in 2016
he won a silver in that event crystal
gomanson global news
london canada's medal count is now
14 and that puts us in 14th place in the
overall standings with three golds
four silvers and seven bronze medals
canada is on pace to have one of its
best showings ever
in the seven summer olympics over the
last 25 years canada has won on average
three gold medals in tokyo we have three
already with one week to go
in total medals canada has reached the
podium just under 20 times on average
and with 14 so far in these games we
could reach our highest standing
in the last quarter century u.s
gymnast simone biles has withdrawn from
the final of the women's floor event
the four-time gold medalist has
withdrawn from several finals this week
citing her struggles with mental health
it leaves only one
event for biles to possibly compete in
the balance beam
on tuesday olympic organizers report 18
new games-related covet 19 cases
including one athlete
the infections bring the total games
related cases to 259.
more than 275 thousand tests have been
administered
athletes are screened daily and their
movement is strictly curtailed
but olympic officials are investigating
an outdoor drinking party at the
athletes village
involving multiple competitors rule
breakers can be removed from the village
and have their olympic credentials taken
away
six people have been banished so far
including two
judo silver medalists from georgia who
took a sightseeing tour
around tokyo here in this country
another province is set to move ahead
with its next phase of recovery
newfoundland and labrador eased some
public health restrictions today
increasing restaurant capacity and
allowing larger gatherings
and changes to the mass mandate could
come in another week
the province has no confirmed cases of
coven 19 at the moment
it's a different story elsewhere in the
country where the delta variant is
causing numbers to rise
as global's sarah comadina reports
that's raising concern among medical
professionals that ending pandemic
protocols too quickly
will result in a harder hit from the
next wave
it was important for nija bakshi to
bring her daughters to the third day of
rallies in alberta
protesting the province's restriction
roll back only a few months away from
being able to have our kids vaccinated
and so why
rushing while the physician acknowledges
restrictions eventually need to be
lifted
she stresses right now just doesn't feel
right why are we doing this now why are
we abandoning testing and tracing
and if we're going to do that how are we
going to mitigate the risk to our
children risk to the
vulnerable population that cannot be
vaccinated and i think a bit more
transparency is necessary
saskatchewan recently eased its coven 19
restrictions
and it's now seeing a spike in
infections the province's active cases
are climbing
routine levels not seen in more than a
month it's sort of like an expression of
you know wishing that kobe 19
is gone from these provinces
when in fact we may be seeing a
beginning of a resurgence new brunswick
has already seen a resurgence of coven
19 just days after dropping virtually
all of its restrictions but the growing
cases in other provinces isn't stopping
newfoundland and labrador from entering
its stage two of reopening plan
15 days ahead of schedule we'll be
keeping a close eye on things
we'll see we'll probably be able to
learn from alberta's experience in this
regard
despite concerns from across the country
alberta maintains its chief medical
health officers
recommendations are informed by science
not politics
it comes as little comfort to bakshi we
aren't there with all of the things that
we can be doing to protect our children
so
it might be rooted in science but timing
is important
sarah comedina global news edmonton
as the delta variant spreads across the
country experts say we could face a
fourth wave in the pandemic
it may not prove as dire as previous
waves but it will target one group in
particular
the unvaccinated and as karen lieberman
reports
that includes children the next wave i
think will
be largely in children the prediction
should come as no surprise
says this emergency physician who points
out this is now a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
and children under 12 aren't yet
eligible for the shot
i think schools are going to be the the
front lines of this next wave
i don't expect the death tolls to be
what they were i don't expect the
hospital usage and icu occupancies will
be what they were
with over 80 percent of eligible
canadians now vaccinated with their
first dose
and approximately 65 fully vaccinated
doctors say the virus is likely to
target those who have not had the
vaccine at all
and come september i suspect that we
will see
what we've seen in england and what
we're seeing in the states and some
other countries
i think kids will be a particular focus
we'll see a lot more cases
in kids these parents are conflicted
about whether to vaccinate their 12 year
old daughter
for kids i don't know it's a little bit
early for me
for me it's better kids get vaccinated
go to school
it's very important for school ontario
premier doug ford has said a back to
school plan
will be released early in the week and
that the province is ready for september
meantime the medical officer of health
revealed there will be a
separate set of rules for students based
on their vaccination status
if you are two dose vaccinated plus 14
days we'll offer you a test if you've
been a contact of a high risk person so
someone that's had
ongoing fever and cough or increasing
shortness of breath
if you test negative you can go right
back to school you can go right back to
work
if you are not immunized and you've been
in
contact with a high risk contact you'll
be off
for a minimum of 10 days and be
subjected to two tests
still this toronto mother says she will
not be vaccinating her children who are
under
12 when they are eligible if kids in 12
were like filling up the hospitals and
the icu's
it would be a completely different story
but they're not although children are
unlikely to get a severe case of covid19
this pediatric infectious disease expert
says they do remain
vulnerable to the virus and its long
lasting effects
i've had families where you have healthy
young teenagers that get coveted and
then they have
all the classical long-haul symptoms
that adults have if they choose not to
get the vaccine
she adds they should learn from home
this mother hopes to avoid that
he would love to be vaccinated too and
he will be soon but
yeah he's looking forward to it he wants
to see his friends he wants to be in
class and learn
karen lieberman global news toronto
millions of eligible americans don't
want to be vaccinated
health officials are desperate to change
their minds as that delta variant gains
speed
meantime around 20 percent of all new
cases in the u.s are coming from florida
and as jennifer johnson reports that
doesn't seem to concern the state's
governor
florida is america's new hotbed in the
coven 19 pandemic
recording over 21 000 new cases in one
day its highest number
ever nationwide new cases are now
averaging more than 70 000 a day
patients are showing up sick today and
last week
and unfortunately this is going to
continue for at least another six weeks
universal resort and sea world are now
joining walt disney world and asking
visitors to wear masks indoors
welcome back but florida's republican
governor is rejecting any statewide
rules
there will be no restrictions and no
mandates in the state of florida
but with the delta variant quickly
spreading president joe biden says new
federal mandates may happen
in all probability the pace of
vaccinations did increase over 20
percent last week but experts are
frustrated there are still 100 million
unvaccinated americans we've really got
to get those people
to change their minds make it easy for
them convince them do something
to get them to be vaccinated because
they are the ones that are propagating
this outbreak the us is keeping eyes on
israel as it becomes the first country
in the world to give booster shots to
residents over 60
as the vaccines start to lose
effectiveness we've decided to add this
vaccination in order to keep up the
level of it that we need
in order to fight the delta variables in
america dr
fauci says things will get worse with
this latest surge warning of more pain
and suffering ahead
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up turkey's tourists on the run
as deadly wildfires burn toward the
beaches
[Music]
firefighters are battling flames in
southern turkey as wildfires threaten
towns and resorts at least eight people
have died in the fires
thousands have been evacuated with
panicked tourists and residents fleeing
by
boat a heat wave along the aegean and
mediterranean coasts
is being blamed for some of the worst
wildfires in a decade
and neighboring greece isn't being
spared the same heat wave is sparking
evacuations
dozens of homes have been destroyed in
several villages
15 people have been hospitalized for
breathing issues from the smoke
officials say it could get worse
temperatures in greece are expected to
reach
45 degrees this week here in this
country an evacuation order has been
issued for a cabin community
in the southern interior of bc as dry
and windy weather fuels an
out of control wildfire people were told
to leave
east gate south of princeton on saturday
as the garrison lake fire grew to nearly
8 200 hectares
it's one of more than 90 out-of-control
fires in a highly active fire season in
the province
as of today fires have scorched more
than half a million hectares of land in
bc
that far surpasses the 10-year average
of 349 000 hectares
still ahead the pandemic is worsening
the military crisis
in myanmar
afghan forces are in fierce battles with
the taliban as the terror group carries
out assaults on three major cities
kandahar lashkarga and herat have all
come under heavy fire
afghanistan's ministry of defense sent
hundreds of commandos
to herat in a bid to prevent militants
from taking control
of the economically important city the
u.s military is supporting government
forces with air strikes
but the taliban is rapidly seizing
territory throughout the country
as the u.s and nato troops withdraw
after nearly 20 years
the united nations says more than 300
000 afghans have fled the fighting and
many are leaving the country
after the u.s began its withdrawal in
may
it's been six months since myanmar's
military seized control of the country
the head of the regime who appointed
himself prime minister promises to hold
elections two years from now
but the southeast asian country also
known as burma has been in turmoil since
the february first coup
protesters have persisted in their calls
for the release of democratically
elected leader aung san tsuchi
in the face of brutal crackdowns on
dissent now
activists say the military junta is
weaponizing kovid 19
against its own people redmond shannon
reports
another clamber for oxygen during a
brutal rise in covet 19 cases
this time in myanmar allegedly made
worse by the military regime withholding
medical supplies from its opponents
healthcare workers are being attacked
and arrested
the virus is spreading through the
population
very fast indeed
on sunday leader minong yang blamed the
opposition for the virus spread
marking six months since his coup he is
promising
free and fair elections by august 2023
with two more years of a state of
emergency
if he actually believes in democracy
and democratic values he wouldn't stage
a coup
on fest of february and continue killing
civilians until today
so again these are empty promises
is a burmese democracy activist just
like her father
he was jailed at the start of the coup
months of protests since then have seen
hundreds of deaths
and thousands of arrests quintone says
the previous regime of aung sang tsuchi
was deeply flawed too accountable to the
military
but it was democratically elected in
burma we never had
a genuine or even a you know democracy
at all
in city areas yes we had a relative
freedom but in ethnic area
um human rights abuses and human rights
violations continue
in that 10 years period including the
persecution and killing of rohingya
muslims in 2017
actions ottawa calls genocide long-term
change
she says will need more international
pressure like the sanctions imposed by
canada
and others they have been able to get
away with
all these atrocities not from not only
from the 1st of february but from
many many decades and so they have this
sense of impunity that they can get away
with
almost everything leaders in the region
meet monday to appoint an
envoy to broker talks between the junta
and the opposition
and this week the first trial of su chi
is set to wrap
redmond shannon global news london
up next canadian politics heats up again
but why do very few black voices have a
say in it
you're watching global national
[Music]
across the country canadians are marking
the first official emancipation day
it commemorates the abolition of slavery
in the british empire in eighteen thirty
four
in march the federal government voted to
recognize emancipation day annually on
august the first
senator wanda thomas bernard who led the
push
says this is just the start the national
recognition
of emancipation day signals
the beginning of what we do next we need
to have
education about black history woven
across
curriculum and all year long
that's one of the things an apology
we've not had an apology
the end of slavery did not bring an end
to discrimination in this country
black canadians have faced barriers in
voting rights and in holding public
office
that is still reflected in parliament
today black canadians make up 3.5
percent of the population
but barely 2 percent in the senate and
in the house of commons
when voters don't see themselves
represented engaging them in
elections is a challenge ross lord
reports on the consequences
and the efforts to bring change in nova
scotia
on election night 1993 wayne adams made
history
he became the first black member of the
nova scotia legislature
almost three decades later the number of
black mlas in the province
is stuck at one i hadn't visited that
there'd be a floodgate
opening after my election with
many african nova scotians applying for
the
a career in public life the sting of
stalled progress hurts most in
communities like north preston
where most residents are black and which
bears the brunt of systemic racism
i think for especially for nova scotia
having only one
black mla is definitely not enough there
are new efforts underway
for the first time elections nova scotia
has hired an outreach officer
to increase participation in african
nova scotian communities like this one
voting is very important in african nova
scotians community
in particular we don't really pay much
attention to that because we don't see
representation from ourselves very much
so in the election
process so this is one of the reasons
why i'm here operation black vote says
there are 11 black candidates in the
nova scotia election from an expected
total of
almost 200 candidates in the provincial
writing that includes north preston
all three parties have nominated black
candidates
but efforts to promote participation are
still undermined by racial controversy
provincial liberal candidate angela
simmons who's a lawyer
is filing an official complaint against
the rcmp
simmons and her husband dean a police
officer say they feared for their lives
after they were pulled over at gunpoint
by rcmp this month
this is why it's important to have
somebody like her at the decision-making
table
because she can talk about her lived
experience
of driving in nova scotia and being
pulled over by the police and the
experiences she had
the rcmp defends its officers saying the
couple's car matched the description of
a suspect in a shooting incident
federally progress is also sluggish more
than a half century after lincoln
alexander became the first black member
of parliament
there are seven black mps in the 338
seed house of commons
we seem to not be building but replacing
black and black elected officials and
that's something that we want
to change in nova scotia
and across canada that change is
happening more slowly
than surely ross lord global news north
preston nova scotia
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm eric sorenson
tonight your canada is clearwater lake
regional park
in saskatchewan we would love to see
your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching
farah nasser will be back at the anchor
desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]